♪ ♪
>> Sean: UNFORTUNATELY, WE
HAVE TO END WITH SAD NEWS FOR
MATRIARCH OF THE BUSH FAMILY,
FORMER FIRST LADY BARBARA BUSH
PASSED AWAY TONIGHT AT THE AGE
OF 92.
FLAGS OF THE GEORGE W. BUSH
PRESIDENTIAL LIBRARY LIBRARY IN
COLLEGE STATION, TEXAS, ARE
FLYING AT HALF-STAFF TONIGHT.
MRS. BUSH, I MET HER, SHE WAS A
STRONG, LOVELY, FUNNY, GREAT,
PATRIOTIC WOMAN.
HER FAMILY GAVE HER THE NICKNAME
"ENFORCER."
SHE HAD AN INCREDIBLE SENSE OF
HUMOR.
SHE SERVED THIS COUNTRY WITH
HONOR, GRACE, DIGNITY, AND
INTEGRITY, AND OF COURSE TONIGHT
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND,
PRESIDENT GEORGE H.W. BUSH.
THEY WERE MARRIED 73 YEARS.
WE ARE ALSO TOLD, OBVIOUSLY
EVERYBODY'S HEARTBROKEN, BUT HE
IS BEING SUPPORTED BY THE FAMILY
AND APPRECIATES ALL OF YOUR WELL
WISHES A MESS.
ONE OF HER SONS COME
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH
MUTTERED A STATEMENT, "MY DEAR
MOTHER HAS PASSED ON AT THE AGE
OF 92.
LAURA, BARBARA, JENNA, AND I ARE
SAD BUT OUR SOULS ARE SETTLED
BECAUSE WE KNOW HERS IS.
BARBARA BUSH WAS A FABULOUS
FIRST LADY END OF MOVEMENT
UNLIKE ANY OTHER WHO BROUGHT
LEVITY, LOVE, AND LITERACY TO
MILLIONS.
TO US, SHE WAS SO MUCH MORE.
MOM KEPT US ON HER TOES, KEPT US
LAUGHING TILL THE END.
I AM A LUCKY MAN THAT BARBARA
BUSH WAS MY MOTHER.
MY FAMILY WILL MISS HER DEARLY
AND WE THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PRAYERS AND GERT      YOUR GOODW
PRAYERS AND GERT      YOUR GOODS
PRAYERS AND GERT      YOUR GOODE
PRAYERS AND GERT      YOUR GOOD.
PRAYERS AND GERT      YOUR GOOD"
THE WHITE HOUSE AS THE
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP AND THE
FIRST LADY MELANIA JOIN THE
NATION AND CELEBRATING THE
INCREDIBLE LIFE OF THE FIRST
LADY AND THE THOUGHTS, PRAYERS,
CONDOLENCES ARE WITH THE ENTIRE
BUSH FAMILY AND MANY THANKS FOR
HER MANY YEARS OF SERVICE TO